bei ihrem studio ist jetzt stefanie
meint stefanie du wirst mir jetzt die
sieben wichtigsten fragen zum thema
impfstoff beantworten fangen auch direkt
an
wer hat gerade die nase vorn im rennen
um den impfstoff
ja da gibt es mehrere hoffnungsträger
sozusagen insgesamt sind 180
einrichtungen und labore die gerade
forschen in china ist man besonders weit
aber auch in den usa und in europa alles
klar wie weit ist deutschland
deutschland darf zurzeit zwei impfstoffe
testen am menschen ist also sozusagen in
der klinischen studie dass ein
unternehmen über das reden wir gleich
bei ihren tag ist am weitesten
die sind in der quali der letzten phase
kilo weg ein weiteres unternehmen aus
tübingen test in der ersten phase bayern
tag da ist gerade angesprochen die haben
heute eine produktionsstätte gekauft was
bedeutet das naja das bedeutet
hauptsächlich dass sie sich darauf
vorbereiten sozusagen den impfstoff zu
produzieren und an uns zu liefern so zu
sagen damit wir impfen können
das ist ein sehr großes werk in marburg
von novartis die sind eine moderne
produktionsstätte und die sollen 750
millionen impfdosen produzieren das ist
gesagt 750 millionen impfdosen ist das
zu viel oder zu wenig das klingt erst
mal wahnsinnig viel wenn wir hier aus
deutschland denken also nun
vergleichswerte grippeimpfstoffs ist so
jährlich 16 millionen dosen diese für
deutschland gebraucht werden aber zum
einen muss man sagen nur warten möchte
das natürlich nicht nur in deutschland
vermarkten verkaufen sondern auch
weltweit dafür ist es dann nicht mehr
viel und wir wissen noch nicht wie viele
dosen bier überhaupt für eine person
brauchen werden sehr wahrscheinlich wird
es jeder mensch sich mindestens zweimal
impfen müssen er wirklich ins arme
reiche junge alte wer kriegt die impfung
ja das steht so genau nicht fest es gibt
ein pandemieplan an dem der wir gerade
noch mal überarbeitet da werden solche
dinge drin stehen
wahrscheinlich ist das risiko gruppen
vor allem medizinisches personal zuerst
geimpft wird
so empfiehlt es auch die vero weil sie
eben sehr leichtes virus bekommen und
auch leicht überträger werden und wie
sieht es aus wenn privatpatienten
möglicherweise vor kassenpatienten geben
dafür gibt es das ja keine indizien
möglich ist es auch das wird uns aus der
pandemieplan beantworten können und die
wichtigste frage zum schluss bahn kommt
der impfstoff
daran ändert sich nichts egal wie oft
für die frage stellen sozusagen
frühestens im ersten quartal nächstes
jahr wahrscheinlich erst im ersten
halbjahr mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren